So far we have referred to machines on the internet
soley by their IP address and then its largely how the
machines address each other. But IP addresses are not very
convienant for users like you and me. We much to prefer
to use host names. The domain name system that makes
this possible amounts to another layer of indirection within the network
layer. The host name, like www.udacity.com, gets translated into an IP
address, which is then used in the ways we've talked about.
This translation is accomplished with the help of domain
name services sprinkled throughout the internet. Suppose I try to
send a packet to www.udacity.com from my computer. To
get the most authoritative answer, my computer would then ask.
The local DNS server, not too far away, probably
on the Comcast network. This in turn would ask the
root name server where it might find a .com
name server which would help it with host names ending
with .com. Having received this response, our DNS
server would then ask this .com name server
for information about udacity.com. When this IP comes
back The server then asks where it might find
www.udacity.com, and when it receives this answer, it
then forwards it back to my computer. This should
be somewhat reminiscent of how a directory system
works. Importantly however, high levels in the tree are
to the right of the host name. Hence. www.udacity.com
is sort of like / com/udacity/www. Now, of course,
we don't actually make all these requests every time
we need to find the IP for www.udacity.com, my computer
will cache the answer and so will the local
name server, not necessarily for my sake. But for
the sake of other clients on the same local
server who might also need an IP for www.udacity.com, and
they would cache the IPs for the root server, and for
the dot com server as well. You can read more about how
domain names are acquired and registered, and how the severs are
kept up to date, in the links provided in the instructor notes.